you said i don't know
wait wait what
[Music]
all righty ty pinky thank you so much
for joining me on 20 minute leaders
thank you for having me you know just
five minutes ago you sent me on whatsapp
pictures of us from 11 years ago in my
bar mitzvah
i still remember that day i'll never
forget it the day that you came to my
house so that we can discuss the bar
mitzvah
plan and half an hour through you
had my watch on your wrist and i'll
never forget that moment
that my mind is just out of this world
i think you traumatized me really i
think that's what happened
if you're being traumatized then you
invite people to your
you know podcast that's weird definitely
definitely no but seriously
i think magic is just so incredibly
powerful
that sensation that it gives people and
the impact that it leaves on people talk
to me a little bit about what you do
you're
this one of the most incredible
magicians in israel talk to me about
that
thank you first of all i think you said
it by yourself i think
magic is the only art form that
creates a unique sensation i think
like for instance when you see a juggler
juggling 10 lines
or in acrobat doing crazy stuff with i
don't know what
you say oh my god that's amazing you
applaud you
respect them for their practice and for
their art
when you see a magic a good magic trick
or magic show
you ask how and this is the
only art form that creates this kind of
question saying
how does it do it like
it's you know it makes this your brain
this is why magic is
happening and still happening for years
and because human being
beings love to being you know intrigued
and say
how cause you know we're intelligent
people we know how things work
when you become an adult you understand
life
and then comes someone and
like this makes your watch disappear
like you say oh my god i'm intelligent
how do you do it without me no
listening right so itai walk me a little
back
walk me a little bit back in your life
because i have to know how do you even
get started as a magician
how do you discover this innate passion
of yours to amaze and intrigue people
um i think i don't know who said it one
of the greatest
painters in the world he said a painter
is a kid
that just continued with his tooling you
know every kid does this when he's a kid
and then you become a painter a famous
painter
with an artist you know when you become
an adult right not all of us
like you know a lot of people can play
the piano not everyone becomes a battle
man
so magic is the same i think most of the
kids
i think mainly boys get
like a magic kit or a magic book or
something like this
and they play with it like for 10
minutes
or a week and then they stop i
i know you're more than that because you
love magic but most of the kids are like
you know doing it for a week or a few
days and then they continue playing
basketball or whatever there are other
hobbies right
and i think magician is just a kid that
continued he just
loved it and did it more and more from
this because
like every time i did the magic trick
for someone when i became i began magic
when i was 15
ish and left it and continue with my
sport and
on the age of like 19 give and take
i came back to this like my passion my
my kids as a kid my passion when i was a
kid
and every person i showed him a magic
trick
told me okay can you have your business
card and i was like
business card this is a hobby man i'm
just doing this
and people told me but you this is like
whatever and when you hear it once you
say
okay that's a great compliment when you
hear it like 15 times a day you say
i think i should make a living out of
this
so so that was at 19 years old when you
decided to to go
from a hobby to actually becoming a
full-time magician
as a profession yeah i think when i was
like 20 i
already like you know got booked for a
serious event
incredible stuff conferences but it was
like
i got paid already for my kids right so
now you're a little bit different in the
field in the sense that you're not just
going and doing street magic and bar
mitzvahs and weddings and so on but you
you do huge conferences and you're doing
a show and
you call it stand-up magic and i i'd
love for you to tell me a little bit
about this combination of stand-up
and magic and how do these two
intertwine with each other
yeah so first of all the combination is
as you said stand up magic you can
understand by the name it combines
stand-up comedy
and magic um the combination i think
is natural because most of the magicians
use comedy or try to be funny at least
i don't know whether they're all funny
but they try they use gags and comedy
bits
and stand-up comedy is being funny so
that
the art form is very similar you know
the crowd the target audience
is the same you know instead of comedy
and magic it's entertainment
it's not like combining dancing with
stand-up comedy
or you know oprah with magic but it
still forces you to be creative enough
to
to to create a show that's that has both
the elements of jokes and
and entertain and entertainment on the
side of comic but also the magis
the magician's wow factor yeah actually
it's much more than just
comedy and and jokes it's literally i
needed to begin a new art from the
beginning
being a stand-up comedian for the crowd
it's okay it's like the same he's very
funny
he uses very good jokes it's not like
you know a joke or two in my
show i have like a set of 10 minutes
with a mind just to set a comedy back
like block we call it just the comedy
set in the middle of the magic tricks
so it it was literally you know like
into yourself a new art room from the
beginning
wow it was difficult for me for the
crowd it's like it's very funny
they don't know the difference i think
like actually a week ago i spoke with
someone that saw my show
and she told me i loved the act and you
know what your magic tricks
they were good also say they're amazing
i've been doing this for 15 years of
course they were good
but she perceived my show as a stand-up
comedian
using magic tricks and i think that the
main
actually issue with my show is whether
one
comes to see the act when he thinks it's
a magic
show or a stand-up comedy show because
if he thinks it's a magic show it will
be damn funny
and if he thinks it's just a stand-up
comedy it will be very surprising
i love it i love it you're not just a
magician you're also actually an
entrepreneur and i had the pleasure of
coming to one of your sorcerers
sundays in tel aviv which was one of the
most
incredible night out experiences i've
had uh
tell me a little bit about this project
and and you actually do it with a lot of
your magician friends
where you just amaze people every sunday
at a restaurant
yeah actually it's a weekly show the
longest weekly show in israel
like running for six and a half years uh
prior to the kobe 19 of course right and
actually yeah the format is a dinner
show and the idea was founded about the
principle of
there isn't a dinner show in israel
and there isn't a good entertainment in
english
in israel like if you have friends or
family from abroad people come to israel
and they can take them to the cinema or
to you know to a restaurant
and it's not entertainment in english
every city in the world it's the same
when i was in argentina i went to see a
tango dinner show or in spain flamingo
or the opposite
so every city a big city tourist city
there's a spinner show show
entertainment whatever and it's almost
always in the language of the city of
the country
sure and israel is the same when you
come to israel there isn't
anything in english yeah we this is
how we we began thinking about this we
said okay we're gonna do a dinner show
in english entertainment for english
speakers with magic
because magic is cool and everyone loves
magic it's for adults of course
yeah and the cool part is that every
show every week the show differs like
right
to change it yeah we have like you know
10 15 magicians
all speaking english fluent and like for
instance we have four magicians this day
and someone comes back after three
months with his sister that came from
south africa or whatever
they see a new act because there are
four new magicians
so people see the show over and over
again we have people coming like
10 times and like 12 times wow
no and it's not just that the show on
stage is different but it's also
the interaction with the people i mean
the magicians go around the tables and
they come up to you
and you really get that whole that whole
vibe
which is just just the whole experience
is incredible so italia i have to ask
we're doing this over zoom now ideally
we would be face to face
in israel but with kovid you're still
doing shows and you're still
entertaining people and you're still
doing conferences
how do you do that during kobe times how
do you do magic over
a computer screen so at the beginning it
was like
okay we'll just wait for this to pass
yeah and we'll go back to our lives and
then we were like
okay it takes more time than we expected
yeah
i mean that's i think all of the world
things like me
and like okay it's a thing
so actually i thought about you know
zoom i said okay i'm gonna do
shows on zoom it's very different
because you know i don't have the crowd
there you know the interaction and
bringing people on stage and hearing the
laughs and then i said to myself
myself it's not the same thing
so don't don't forget about it
yeah you can't you know wait for the
crowd to applaud and say okay you can't
you know and
just do your show and expect it to be
the same with zoom
no it's not the same and it will not be
the same you need to adapt yourself and
adapt the sh
though for zoom like last night he did a
show
and like i want to do some jokes okay so
i did my bibs
and i put everyone on silence because i
need i need them to hear me
instead of them hearing you know people
in the house right right so i can't hear
the laughs i can see them laughing
but it's silent it's like a bad comedy
club
silence you can hear all the crickets
from from outside like i do a gag
and that was my mother and then here
wow and i can see them laughing so
they're having fun and they enjoyed it
but it's difficult
it's different that's what it is can you
get it can you get
the the magic cross that astonishment
you know sometimes people when you flip
a bottle and you show that it's empty
now
people want to go and see it and they
want to put their hand under it to see
that it's really in the air
now they can't do that right because now
it's all virtual
um yes they can't physically wise but i
think actually it's a philosophical
discussion because i think
the magician that the people the skeptic
they say yeah you know i
i hate magic i want to figure out the
tricks the only thing i want is to
figure out the tricks
i think this person isn't problematic i
think the problem is
with the magician performing i think
that if the magician like
magic when you think about it it's very
very condescending
like i think seinfeld said it the best
seinfeld said a magic show goes like
this
here's a coin now it's gone you're
stupid
this is exactly like most magicians
do they make you feel stupid
and i think it's a problem i think when
you're
condescending and you're being you know
um how do you say it
um patronizing yeah
on on your your audience's expense yeah
it's a problem
don't do stupid when they feel stupid
they want to figure out the tricks
i can see all the time i see my my
colleagues going on tv
and their first phrase is okay today
i brought something that will blow your
mind i'm gonna fool you today
why i think magic isn't the competition
like
me against you if you figure out the
trick you want if
i fool you i win right this is not the
game
this is not you know like basketball a
winner and a loser i think we're both
on the same side we're having fun i'm
here to entertain you
and you i love it have fun let's do it
together i love it and i think the crowd
feels it when when they get this feel
this vibe
they don't want to figure out the tricks
like in the beginning of my show i do a
comedy bit just just about this about
you know
the people trying to figure out the
tricks and whatever and
the subtext is don't not because i won't
fool you i will fool you
this is not the idea this is not my
mission i love it no and i mean you're
so approachable on stage and
your show is mainly for adults right
from what i remember correctly with
with some of the jokes but but really i
mean i've seen quite a few magic shows
because i'm a huge magic fan myself
and and yours your show is one of the
most the one one of the most that i
enjoyed the most because you're so
approachable and because you just make
it such a unique experience
as a friend and it's not as i'm up here
you're down in the audience now just get
ready to be fooled and good luck
figuring it out itai i have to ask we're
here over the
we're here over zoom can you show me
something and give me the experience of
what it's like
to to be in a magic show and covet 19
times
i i can try i can try let's do this
um can you see the clip
yes i can alright
let's put it here
i'm good i want you to think of
magically place it on the floor
nailed it no not yet wait a second let's
do this you know what
i'll do this and this oppa
all right nailed it
do you want to think of any three-digit
number
okay got it no three
don't go with three three three because
that's very obvious ah shoot okay
now okay i have a new one you're good
yeah
you can see it what is it six eight nine
459 yes
i'll go with six in the beginning six at
nine
i have hearing problems so let's go with
my number okay it's okay sounds good
i'll do this first possible
you said i don't no wait wait what
that's a note to drop like a mic drop
itali what
what the f what the hell was that
no way okay i did not photoshop this
now your viewers will think yeah they
planned this i swear
he's playing along this is okay you know
this was maybe one of the simplest but
most impressive things i've ever seen
i don't i don't think i can continue to
do this interview right now i'm a little
bit shook
[Laughter]
and i was thinking of two eight nine in
the beginning and i was like you know no
i'll change it to six eight nine
yeah i know i know okay that was just
crazy okay let's just move on
and then i'll go i'm not i'm not gonna
sleep tonight
this is just crazy itai and humanity is
changing
things are becoming more technological
people are becoming impatient
people's standards are rising because of
technology
all the immediate gratification what is
happening to the magic industry
and you know because it seems that magic
today is is still pretty similar to what
it was when houdini
was alive but now things are things are
becoming more technological i don't know
anything so maybe you can correct me
and where are we headed with this
i don't know where we're heading but
things do change humanity change
technology yeah think change and magic
correlates magic changes also you know
in the it's not houdini actually one of
the first magicians that made
magic as a theatrical like prestigious
thing he wore
suit and everything was robert houdini
it's not houdini who didn't indeed
escapology
robert hundine did you know big boxes
and doves and then the illusionist the
grand illusions with that
sawing a woman woman in half and then
whatever
yeah this was in the 50s and 60s and 70s
in the 80s we had origami you know
reading minds
think change and nowadays people aren't
that naive so
they don't want you to read their mind
so think that the story
changed interesting like a psychological
mentalism darren brown
in england he began yeah yeah this yeah
this thing is about you know
i influenced you and i read your body
language right
so things change you can't say magic is
the same because magic
isn't nowadays sawing a woman in women
women in half
right there are magicians that still do
it but they
can't make a living i guess interesting
stuck in the 80s
yeah and so what does technology fit
into this
technology do fit into this and
with technology we have new magic tricks
and we have a
marco tampa doing stuff with ipads and
we have very visual stuff and things do
change
and things change like you know like
like 15 years ago we had david blaine
doing magic
tricks in the sea in the street you know
street magic yeah
and he understood people are more
interested about their reactions
so david blaine what he did not only the
tricks but
instead of putting the camera on the
magician
they pivot and they showed the reaction
he did a small trick and they
they had the crowd yelling for one
minute so that was plain and then we had
dynamo and whatever
nowadays we have instagram magicians no
presentations
no nothing no patience for them for the
numbers people just see a trick
five seconds bam bam bam and it's done
so i think this is the the way things
change i don't know whether it's just
the technology but it's the medium
nowadays with the zoom yes so
fascinating
things change definitely i can't believe
it i said
20 minutes are going to go away so
quickly and they have
unbelievable right i have to put you on
the spot once and i didn't prepare you
for this i'm sorry in advance
but i want you to tell me three words
that you would best describe yourself as
or if i ask
anybody watching your show what would
when i think of a thai pinky what are
three words that i think of
when i think when i picture itai
wow okay actually three words that i
will describe myself are very similar to
the three words
one seeing my show will describe me i
think i'm bringing myself to the
stage so when people see me after the
show they feel like they know me this is
good this is my
idea so i would go with
in this order funny
intelligent humble
interesting i love it honest
i i love it i can't wait to see another
show i can't believe it's been 11 years
since we met when i was just 13 years
old and and
and the uh will appear from your bar
mitzvah boom
i love it with your editing i love it
itai
thank you so much stay safe thanks
michael see you soon
bye bye
[Music]